good morning to you guys who are here
live but good day to everyone who is
viewing this class online
welcome to Y Combinator's second annual
massively open online course startup
school so I'm Jeff Ralston I'm a partner
here at Y Combinator and one of the
organizers of this year's startup school
starting today we're hoping that Y sees
knowledge about entrepreneurship will
help spur incredible innovation from all
of you here and out there to create a
normos value for for the societies in
which you live for your friends your
families your employees and for
yourselves we're going to cover just a
few things before we actually get
started on the course so I hope you'll
bear with us first more companies than
ever before asked to take place take
part in start-up school this year 27,000
companies from around the world asked to
be part of it
yeah that's a number that kind of blows
me away every time I think about it
15,000 of those companies ask to
actually participate in the class and
that's from over a hundred countries in
over eight thousand cities around the
world really extraordinary numbers now
some of you may have heard that we had
in fact intended to actually only allow
about a quarter of those 15,000 to take
the class just because there are actual
infrastructure limitations well I don't
know if you did hear didn't hear but
there was a slight glitch in our process
and in the end and then we accepted all
15,000 companies give or take
we accepted everyone its 15,000 give or
take this means that this will be by far
the largest class for startups that Y
Combinator or for that matter anyone
else has ever taught so congratulations
on being part of the biggest class I
don't know if that's great or not but
congratulations you're you're still part
of it um so like let me just do a brief
interlude about startup school my
competitor began in 2005 by funding more
companies simultaneously than had ever
been done before even though we only
started with 8 companies in our first
batch today we fund over 300 companies
every year and work with them in an
intense three-month program but there
are many many more thousands who
actually apply for each one of those
spots and we always knew that there was
a possibility of our knowledge having
greater reach so that's why we started
startup school
to maximize how many companies we could
reach with our knowledge to get it to as
many companies around the world to
maximize and this is our stated goal as
a as a company the innovation in the
world because we think that that is
almost always a really good thing we
would like to find a way for every star
to succeed and yes there is
self-interest here because it would be
awesome if one or more of you out there
today was the next huge wear.i
Combinator company and why not right we
first experimented with the idea of
greater reach in 2014 with a course
taught by Y Combinator's president Sam
Altman called
how to start a startup it was a
conventional course taught at Stanford
with the difference that there was an
online component this the the lectures
were videoed and then placed online
last year we rethought that course as a
massively open online course with the
difference that the classes would be
coupled with online access community
software tools and of course most
impotant most importantly weekly
meetings with groups and check-ins so
this year we're going to reprise that
idea with some notable differences we're
still going to have a combination of
in-person and online classes but we have
revamp software this year most of the
curricula will be taught by YC partners
and YC alumni there's as I mentioned new
software for community and for
management there's scale we're scaling
larger than we ever have before the
timing of this class is different last
year was taught in this spring this year
is timed to coincide with a YC batch so
that hopefully as many of you all as
possible who want to apply to the YC
winter 2019 batch can conveniently do so
there's also a $10,000 grant non-equity
grant available for hundred companies
who complete and graduate from the
course and in a few moments my partner
adora will go through the criteria for
graduation also for the first time we've
collected really an extraordinary
library of start-up content at the URL
you see there and I really encourage you
guys to go look at it you can find that
there's a there's a link to it online
when you log in to the site it's
available it's a it's an open library
available to anyone and also we have
some incredible deals for the 15,000
companies that you can also see when you
log in online and I
to call out the the the folks offering
deals were not expecting to offer those
deals to 15,000 companies there's a big
surprise and and a number of whom really
really really stepped up Amazon Web
Services is offering a thousand dollar
credit to every single thousand dollars
of AWS credits to everybody Thank You
Amazon thank you google for offering a
thousand dollars in Google cloud and
firebase credits and to YC companies
stripe and Clerke have also really
strapped up stripe is offering an
incredible deal on stripe at lists 50%
off for all of the companies and $5,000
of fee free payment processing and
Clerke is also giving a fantastic deal
$5.99 gets you formation a bank account
and lots more from Clerke so briefly I'm
gonna take you through the curriculum
here our first week kicks off with an
introduction to get startup school and
your company off the ground and then for
the next three weeks we dig in deeply
into building something that people want
and then figuring out how to get users
for that something then we spend a bunch
of time talking about how to effectively
run a start-up with an interlude by YC
partner Dalton Caldwell in week six
which will I think you'll find very
helpful in terms of thinking through how
to apply to I see how to succeed at an
interview with YC and NYC itself and
then we finish up with some lectures on
fundraising and with an eye towards the
future another new aspect to startup
school this year something I'm really
excited about which is something we're
calling conversations there's gonna be
two kinds of conversations real ones
live in-person
with a notable expert in some useful
domain as well as a mas ask me any
things on our forums where you where the
experts will respond to questions both
asked in advance and live actually this
week we have an AMA tomorrow and a
conversation on Friday which you can
learn that you'll learn more about so if
it's not obvious we're doing a lot more
this year a lot of new things and some
of those things aren't planned weren't
planned so we asked you to bear with us
this is our small team we're very
effective and very tight but small but
we'll fix everything that goes wrong as
quickly as possible and respond to you
as quickly as possible understand that
there's a big scale here and there are
there are many companies that are taking
startup school and we are going to do
our best to make your all of your
experiences as successful as possible so
now adora the YC partner with whom I'm
organizing startup school is going to go
over some of the details as to how the
2018 class is actually going to work all
right so I am going to talk about the
structure of the course there are five
main components to this course what you
see up here weekly class lectures weekly
group office hours company updates form
and presentation day so I'm going to go
over all of these and at the end I will
demo how it actually works in the
software all right start off so as you
already know each Tuesday we will be
recording around two hours of lectures
on a variety of topics related to
building and growing your startup which
Jeff already did a good preview of
before most lectures we will be sending
out what we call a prep material which
is like videos and slides to review so
that the speakers can get to the good
stuff
ASAP instead of spending too much time
on the mundane basics please take the
time to review those notes if you can if
you're in the San Francisco Bay Area you
will be able to attend these lectures in
person unfortunately
there's only a limited amount of seats
so we can't fit everyone each time but
we will confirm via RSVPs if you can
attend the lecture so please only come
if you get an invite to that particular
lecture we will start at 10 a.m. each
Tuesday please be in your seat by then
the speaker will give the lecture and
then QA will be done afterwards however
most of you will actually be watching
the lectures online we will be posting
the lectures every Wednesday after the
Tuesday lecture around 12 p.m. or at
least by 12 p.m. each week we encourage
you to just watch whenever you get a
chance all right
so weekly group office hours as you may
or may not know we've already placed you
in groups of 15 to 30 companies each
mostly based on location this is to
provide a more intimate experience
consider this group your immediate
support network for startup school and
hopefully beyond startup school these
are your go-to people when you need help
or you want to discuss something related
to your startup so one of the ways we
make sure you leverage this group
effectively is through weekly group
office hours and we think this is
actually the most important thing to
participate in even more so than
potentially the lectures so you can
think of weekly group office hours as
two things one it's a weekly chicken to
keep everyone accountable and two it's
like a group therapy session where you
can air out your week ask for help and
get feedback from your peers so the way
that group office hours work is pretty
straightforward
each session is led by a moderator the
moderator calls the meeting to order and
then if he or she facilitates a
discussion in which in which one founder
from each company says three things one
their company one-liner to remind
everyone what they're actually working
on which actually is quite a tough thing
to say what you're working on one line
so you should help each other work on
that too is goals for your last week and
why they did why you did or did not meet
that goal and three your biggest problem
or obstacle that the crew can help you
with and then this is followed by
discussion in which each
company spends about five to ten minutes
depending on the number of people
actually show up to group office hours
that week and the moderator goes last so
like I said each group has only one
moderator some groups have been already
assigned a moderator these are
volunteers from the YC founder community
many groups do not have one yet these
groups will need to select one amongst
themselves so if you are in a group
without a mired moderator currently and
you will know this via the software
which I'll show you shortly
your homework is to do this ASAP by
Thursday so how to select a moderator
for your group first ask yourself if you
are that person do you want to do this
this involves extra time energy and
thought and so just be cognizant of the
extra work before volunteering you will
need to set the weekly schedule for your
group encourage and drive discussions
and constantly ask the group for input
and guide the conversations should you
choose to accept this mission we will be
running a moderator training session
this Friday it's going to be a live
stream at 9:00 a.m. Pacific and we will
be posting the live stream the recording
of it afterwards if you can't attend so
you should immediately get together with
the group via the two channels we
provide which is video chat and group
form or some other way that's best for
you and figure this out one easy way to
figure this out is whoever volunteers
first gets the role so there's no
arguing there so please submit your
choice by Friday so that the right
person knows to attend the training
session here is the link to submit we
will send this out to you afterwards so
you don't really need to write this down
now so the obvious question might be
what if no one in your group volunteers
to be a moderator well the answer is if
no one volunteers then no one in the
group can participate in start-up school
your entire group will be auditing the
class instead whoops I don't know what I
did there but there we go
this seems hard but for this to work we
think having a moderated group office
hours just based on experience is very
important maybe the most important thing
for this entire class so we've made this
a requirement to stay in the course
alright I'm a little bit okay weekly
company updates so sometimes this week
you should actually sit down and think
with your other co-founders about a goal
for startup school that is at least one
key metric that defines what success is
to you by the end of the ten weeks
this might just be launching your
product but hopefully it's some kind of
key metric like monthly recurring
revenue number of active users and so
forth and each week you will be asked to
submit an update of your company in
particular whether you achieved your
weekly goal for this key metric we find
that submitting this adds an extra layer
of useful accountability and will help
you to drive to accomplish more than you
would have otherwise so please submit
this by Tuesday end of day Pacific
excluding this week so the first day I
believe is September 3rd alright so one
of the things we're doing new this time
and in which I'm personally excited
about is the community and forum which
some of you may have logged in and
already started posting this is the
place where you can talk to Phil a
founder as you like yourself you can
pull for opinions on a variety of
matters related to your startups and ask
for help for things like what's the best
way to do X Y & Z and so forth we've
also created a private channel for your
group and we think that most of the
conversations will have will actually be
in these private channels talking to
tens of thousands of people will be
almost usually ineffective and tough for
many topics so one of the first things
you do if you haven't already done is
log into the software which is live now
and introduce yourself to your own group
basic form rules apply be nice don't
spam I've already had to delete some
posts so try not to do that only post
things that will be helpful to you and
everyone else if you break these rules
we unfortunately will have to remove you
finally at the end of the course we will
have a virtual presentation day where
you'll pitch your company via video and
slides this is we're telling the story
of your startup is important and Jeff
will go over how to do this and how to
think about it
in a few minutes so while presentation
day is actually optional it's a good way
to use this day to set an ambitious goal
of what you would like to show off to
others in ten weeks from now there will
be many of you who if you take this
seriously will be amazed in ten weeks by
what you can accomplish and what you'll
be able to present by just setting a
goal holding yourself accountable each
week by one submitting updates and
talking about your progress with your
group during group office hours all
right so to help us keep the community
tight and on track together we will be
removing inactive companies
unfortunately so if you don't submit
updates and skip group office hours in
the first two weeks you will be auditing
instead we want to work with you if
you're serious about your startup than
making progress now some of you may
decide this is not the right time to do
your startup and that's obviously
totally fine to officially complete the
course aka to graduate you just need to
do two things one is to submit nine out
of the ten weekly updates and two is to
participate in nine out of the ten group
office hour sessions and that's it and
as you know as Jeff already mentioned we
are giving out 110k equity free grants
for the most promising startups course
completion is the minimum requirement to
be eligible for these grants but
regardless if you're aiming for this or
not we believe the success of your
startup will increase if you actually
complete the course so regardless please
you know we encourage you to just
complete the course finally jeffra kind
of already mentioned this but while
startup school is completely independent
from the YC core program we would love
for as many of you to apply to it as
possible in this vein as Jeff has
pointed out we have a lecture dedicated
to how to create the best application
possible and the best practices for the
in-person interview should you get one
the course just happens to finish just
in time for you to apply on time and so
we hope to see many of you do so yeah I
just wanted
spend a couple of minutes talking about
something that I think is absolutely
vital to startup success but although
it's fundamental is often somewhat
overlooked and that is really the
invention the creation of the story of
your startup this might sound obvious or
basic but it turns out that getting this
right is actually non intuitively
important and the reason that it is so
important is because startups are so
hard they're so very very hard it is
almost certainly going to be the hardest
most difficult thing you will do in your
professional career and if you don't
create a story the right story that you
can tell yourself to keep going when
things go wrong you'll quit and your
startup will die so it's worthwhile my
YC partner Aaron Harris who's going to
be giving a lecture later on in start-up
school thinks and talks a lot about
stories and I'm indebted to him for a
number of the ideas and what I'm about
to say so there are stories and there
are stories and the famous author Ian
Forrester maybe said it best many many
decades ago when he gave this example so
the King died and then the Queen died is
certainly a story but it's not a very
interesting story is it it's not a story
that grabs you it's not a story you
necessarily care about but the King died
and then the Queen died of grief well
there's something there there's
something that grab you there's
something human there there's something
in that story that seems to matter and
it turns out founders spend a lot of
time telling stories they tell stories
about what they're doing they tell
stories about the future that they're
trying to create they tell stories
originally maybe to their parents to
their friends to their family
eventually two co-founders potential
customers partners in the company
investors but most of all they need to
tell a story that resonates with
themselves it's the story of your
startup that will nourish you that will
keep you going through hard times and
setbacks it's a story that will persuade
you to actually do this crazy thing and
it's the story that will maybe just for
those others per Sade them to join you
on your journey how crazy it is to
convince someone else to follow you on
such an uncertain path it's not easy so
we actually spend a lot of time at YC
helping people craft and sometimes even
reimagine their stories so I'd strongly
recommend that you do these things
during these 10 weeks so start with your
idea and then as a dora mentioned create
a 1 preferably one sentence or maybe two
sentence explanation that is so easy to
understand you can stop anyone in the
street and they wouldn't just look at
you blankly when you're telling them
what you do create your what we call
your vertebrae the framework of your
story that captures really what it's all
about and that if you were to tell your
story you would expect hope that people
might just remember because they will
not remember your entire story and
create a 2 minute demo day like pitch
doesn't have to be exactly 2 minutes but
create a pitch that captures the essence
of your story and communicates those
vertebrae in a memorable way and last
but not least work with your co-founders
so that you're on the same page so that
you all share the same story and can all
relate that story tell that story in a
way that's compelling and believable
because when you have it right
we'll be believable and equally
importantly it will be 'rememorable and
it will
I hope sustain you as you go through
your path and your journey
good luck to everyone I hope that
startup school helps everyone realize
the dream and the company you're
creating has a ton of success so adore
come on up we are going to do a quick
Q&A I just want to say one thing about
one part of what Sam talked about which
is we'll figure it out don't minimize
the importance of getting that as part
of the fundamental culture of your team
and in fact as an example Y Combinator
might not feel to you guys like a
startup but it always feels to us like
it's a startup even though we're 15
years old now and a week ago everything
went to hell and we had a pretty big
problem with start-up school and we
weren't quite sure how to deal with it
and our small team sat down together and
everyone said well we'll figure it out
we're going to let everyone in and we'll
figure out how to make it work now you
guys will be the judge of how good a job
we do figuring it out we're going to do
our very best but that sort of attitude
this default towards positive action
makes for great startups any questions
you have we're going to take whatever
questions you have if any then we're
going to take a short break and then
we'll continue with the second half the
second lecture today on startup
mechanics led by our incredible legal
team from Y Combinator who's hiding in
the corner over there so any questions
for adoro myself yes when should we
submit the weekly updates should we do
it nice and early or should we try
get as much done as possible and can
wait as late as possible and submits
them close to the deadline well look the
updates are for you
right so the updates are to derive
progress in your company and it's
usually better to have an update that is
better than worse so you know if you
think you're gonna get five sales
between now and the deadline we'll get
the five sales and have a better update
I would actually in general recommend
doing them on a on a pretty consistent
temporal basis just because that gives
you some clues to your progress like
every week we're going this much but
look they're a week apart so the
importance of a few days is not going to
make or break your startup the important
thing for the updates is to have a
measure that you hold yourself to that
really tells you whether you're making
progress or not because a startup that
doesn't make progress is going nowhere
that's redundant but true
you know that when when the when when
Chesky and Nate and the folks at Airbnb
were at YC they used to wake up every
morning and see their revenue graph and
their bathroom mirror and that drove
them and you know it helped and it
worked out for them so why not you
questions yeah
[Music]
the question is about AWS credits and
you probably missed the beginning but if
you log in to the site you can see all
of the deals that the companies who are
following why accommodator
following startup school yet there are
aw there was a thousand dollars of AWS
credits for all of the participants ya
have what about the group office hours
there's a lot of people in the room who
are all from here so is there like a way
for us to physically do that and then
further like we're in San Francisco so
coming down here is harder so I get more
out of being in a room with other people
and I do like on the internet so if you
look just look at who's in your group
and see where they are can you repeat
the question because on this theorem so
the question is should we be doing group
office hours in person and if so like
how do we go about doing that so we
encourage because most people are
distributed is to do them through the
video chat online and that assures you
know we just click it in you're in if
you do want to do in person that's up to
you but that's something you should work
with your group on yes
so you should if you're having issues
with your account who should you contact
if you're having issues either accounts
you should email startup school at Y
Combinator comm yes so the question is
how will we choose the hundred companies
who get the $10,000 as adora pointed out
the first criterion that we'll look at
is did you actually complete the
requirements of the course if you do
that then we're going to take a number
of measures to see who's the most
promising it's kind of what we do at Y
Combinator we're always trying to judge
who's the most promising so we're going
to look at everyone who graduated and
everyone's status updates and we'll talk
to moderators and we'll look at the the
information we have about the company
and then make judgments as to who we
think is most likely to to be able to
take that ten thousand dollars and do
something useful with it yes in the back
I mean I work on both digital and
can you stand up and speak more loudly
please so I think the question was if
you're working part time on your company
because you have to work full time how
do you stack up well well I think I
think the hard answer there is there's
few startups that are successful working
part time so eventually if you're not
full-time the likelihood that you're
gonna create an epic company by working
a few hours a week even if you know even
if you're amazing and you're working 40
hours a week in one job in 40 hours a
week in another your probability of
success is pretty low can you guys think
of any company any amazing company where
part-time founders actually made it
amazing so I think the question isn't
really to us it's to you how successful
can you make your startup working part
time I think you can get it going but at
some point at some point in your
startups in the in the evolution of your
startup you're going to have to commit
to it if you want to make that startup
real yes there is really no such thing
the question was about like the advisor
Trac program there's really no such
thing there's one program with all
15,000 companies and we're going to try
to make the program as identical for
everyone as possible some grew
everyone's going to have a group some
groups have a built-in moderator some
don't and have to have to add their
moderator look we think we think that's
going to work out very well we'll find
out it's going to depend on you all -
for the folks who choose to be
moderators to take it seriously and to
create a community and a useful group
that actually helps folks as they have
their encounter sessions as they talk
about progress as they talk about
problems and we think that one of the
most important thing
for start-up success is actually to have
a community of folks to whom you can
talk just having that community can be
one of those things that does with your
story sustain you as you as you build
your startup yes so the question is if
you haven't launched yet what should be
a good weekly metric so the obvious
number one thing you could go after is
number of days till public launch and so
that way the way you make progress over
the weeks is the technical milestones
that you need to hit like one two three
and four to get to that so hopefully by
the end of ten weeks you're able to
launch it to either a set of private
beta users or to the world and beyond
that if you're also someone asked us in
the forum to if you're in private beta
right now like you know what's a good
metric also number of days to public
launch but also for example a number of
active users using you or something some
engagement metric that shows that people
are loving what you're building one one
just a fellow on one good rule is to
launch earlier than you think you should
now there are there are exceptions to
that if you're you know if you're
thorough notes and your thing doesn't
work not a good idea so there are
exceptions but in general you should
launch sooner than you think you should
yes
like value and micros I guess like value
is just like a number right it's very
arbitrary so the question was on the
weekly updates and what we mean by value
I don't think it's arbitrary at all like
if it's revenue it should be a real
number if it's users it's a real number
the reason we're not prescriptive about
what that should be is because it
depends so much on the stage of your
startup the sort of startup you have
what we encourage you to do is to try to
figure out what metric is most likely to
be representative of success what
actually tells you that things are going
well it's not a fake one if it's the
number that happens to be the biggest
every week but actually doesn't really
represent whether things are going well
you're getting a ton of registrations
people are signing up for your product
but nobody's using it so you use
registrations as your metric you might
think that that's impressing us but in
the end you're just waving your hands
around something that's not working so
in that case for example maybe active
users was a better metric to use yes
sorry to ask another question we're a
hardware company so the nature of what
we're doing is that we're making
something physical so what is a useful
Hardware metric that you've seen over
time that might be different than what
you've already talked about so the
question was what metrics make sense for
hardware companies look we fund lots of
hardware companies one of our partners
at Eric makovski founded pebble he
probably be much better than than I
would be at answering that question but
every company hardware software hard
Tech if you're building like YC company
boom a supersonic airplane still makes
progress if you're not making progress
what exactly are you doing it might be
that you're trying to find a factory in
China to manufacture your product so
maybe you've made progress on that deal
maybe it's in the design of the product
so the milestone
we've completed the design of the wing
or the engine again I will default to
what I said before there is some way
that you believe that your prior project
your your company your product is
proceeding on a path towards success and
along that path there will be important
milestones those should be your metrics
we have a lot more questions so I'm just
gonna take it I apologize a couple more
questions because I want to give
everyone a bio break and and I want to
move to the next session so just a
couple more yes yes so the question is
how can you connect with YC alumni our
partners to get feedback so we're a lot
of alumni or at least over 100 or
actually in the forum and they'll be
answering your questions Jeff and I will
also be in the forum we were YC partners
so hopefully that covers that and we'll
also have AMAs with other YC partners
for example Eric from pebble will be
doing something for the hardware
startups and so we'll have those
interactions as well so look it's a
great question you know we're there's a
lot of you out there there's 15,000
companies and so we can only give so
much feedback but the whole point of
startup school is to try to give you
know YC knowledge to everyone who can
make use of it so we'll do our very best
to do exactly that all right one more
question yes
yeah
so the question is can I repeat what I
meant by they've heard of the the
vertebra of your story the way I usually
think about that is if you tell let's
say you meet an investor and tell them
I'll give them a little two-minute pitch
for your story you have to remember that
they're gonna hear lots and lots and
lots of pitches they're not going to
remember your entire two-minute pitch
they're probably gonna remember three or
four things from that pitch the
vertebrae the three or four things you
want them to remember so if you if you
build a story and the focus is on
something like you know they walk away
saying oh he's from San Mateo like who
cares we really want them to remember is
we're growing at 30% every week and this
market is a gigantic market and our
product solves an incredibly important
problem for somebody so the vertebrae
are the key elements around which you
build a story the vertebrae are the
elements that are the memorable ones of
what you're building and that comprise
really the essence of your story
hope that helps look we're going to take
a 12 minute break and start again at
11:20 there's coffee and snacks in there
and the bathrooms are over there thank
you
you